Professor John
Merriman: Today I want to
talk about large-scale
industrialization and workers.
Let me say a couple of things,
a couple of general points that
are important,
is that--well,
two things at the beginning,
first of all everywhere,
and particularly in the case in
France,
the Industrial Revolution was
first and foremost a
continuation of forms of
production that were already
there;
that we've over-emphasized the
kind of technological advances,
the super inventions of the
eighteenth century in the
textile industry,
and that even in Britain--and
some of you have heard me say
this in the context of another
course--traditional ways of
producing things,
artisanal and domestic industry
involving women doing outwork,
or domestic industry,
was essential to the process.
The second Industrial
Revolution really depends on
when you want start it up,
really from the mid-1850s on,
is more what--the classical
kind of way that we've come to
consider large-scale
industrialization,
that is, with electricity and
steel, in the other order,
and large-scale units of
production.
So, that's really the first
point.
And the second point is that
for a very long time people who
did economic history,
often whom were economists,
tended to see Britain as this
sort of classic case of
large-scale industrialization,
and even used the most
unfortunate word,
"retarded," when describing
large-scale French
industrialization.
And the reason they kind of
blundered into that kind of
analysis that really missed the
point is that if you added up
the number of factories with x
number of workers,
or if you added up the number
of steam engines,
that France lagged behind
Britain.
But, until the mid-nineteenth
century France is the second
largest industrial economy in
the world,
and then gradually overtaken by
Germany and then eventually
lapped by the United States.
But, one of the reasons why
these economic historians argue
that France couldn't become the
major industrial leader was that
capital formation was less
easily achieved in France,
because the banking and
insurance facilities were not
that, to be sure,
of the equal of Great Britain.
Also, one of the advantages
that England had in large-scale
industrialization was its
geography,
that you had--one of the
reasons why the first railroad
in the world in about 1827--no,
earlier than that,
actually about 1819,
I guess it is--was in England,
north of here,
is that it was carrying coal
down to the sea,
and there's nowhere in England
that's more than seventy-five
miles away from the ocean.
In France you had the kinds of
mine deposits that are so
important.
In Germinal,
you've got them in the Nord,
here, you've got them in
Alsace--of course,
that's disappeared.
You have them down in the
Aveyron, in the Decazeville,
and you have them here and
there in other places,
particularly around
Saint-Étienne.
But they are far from--it's
very difficult to transport coal
and so that was really kind of
the problem.
But, if you look at large-scale
industrialization in France it
still proceeds rather
dramatically,
but in the French way,
still involving artisanal
production, craft production,
in Paris and in other cities,
and still involving,
until quite late in the
century,
rural industry.
As a matter of fact,
just take an example that I
always use because I love the
place,
if you take Reims- r-e-i-m-s-
here, industrial production,
it was a major textile center.
You think of it as being an
ecclesiastical center because of
the coronation of the kings and
all that business and the
magnificent cathedral rebuilt by
the Americans after World War I
and the Basilica of Saint
Rémi,
but in the 1840s and '50s you
still--well, 1830s and 40s--you
still had all sorts of rural
industry that's sort of putting
out work into the countryside,
done largely by women,
and then gradually you have the
growth of large-scale industrial
production,
in the context of factories.
But, well into the 1870s you
still have something like 75,000
embroiderers,
mostly women again,
living in the hinterland of
Nancy.
And in 1871 the average unit of
production in Paris--and Paris
was the region with the biggest
industrial center of France--had
only seven people working in it.
So, if you're looking for huge
sweatshops, huge factories that
you would find in Manchester,
and Sheffield and places like
that, they were pretty rare in
France, and indeed some of the
biggest units of production were
mines.
By the way, Germinal is
really about the Anzin mines,
and they're in the north,
the north of France,
and Anzin is right,
a couple of kilometers
northwest of Valenciennes,
so right near the Belgian
border.
But, over the long run
that--and into this course,
the 1850s and '60s,
which is before this course,
but--the large-scale
industrialization develops more
and more in France.
And, as in Britain,
and as in other places,
in order to have investment in
industry you have to have
capital,
you have to have a sort of
surplus of capital and you have
to have a way of feeding a
growing population,
only very slowly in the case of
France, as you know.
And, so, there is an increase
in production,
in rural production that makes
this possible,
sort of an agricultural
revolution that takes place,
that certainly has,
as we'll see in a week or so,
big problems with the
phylloxera epidemic killing off
the vineyards of France,
which is so important to
agricultural production.
But you have to eat as well as
drink, and so there is an
increase in production of
agriculture all over the place.
And, so, this is very important.
And just another point,
ten--until ten years ago people
still talked about the Long
Depression,
and it's a very unfortunate
term because it gave the sense
that the Depression that gripped
Europe between 1873,
1874 and the mid-1890s was in
any way comparable to the Great
Depression in industrialized
countries,
and in not so industrialized
countries.
But the industrial depression
from 1929--and in the case of
the US, the US doesn't really
get out of it until the massive
arms production following Pearl
Harbor in World War II.
It is a depression,
it's characterized by low
prices, so you don't have these
big sort of catastrophic dips,
but it's a depression which
undercuts the economy in some
way, and particularly hurts
rural people because the prices
of agricultural goods are so
low.
But nonetheless if you
just--this is not an economics
course but it's good to have a
few figures nonetheless--if you
look here,
the percentage of the
population working in industry
in France in 1876 is 27.6
percent of the population,
and in 1896,
twenty years later,
it's 29.2 percent.
So, it's quite clear,
France is still a peasant
society, even though many people
have foots in both worlds.
Miners, for example,
working in, oh,
in mines in the south of France
in a place called Camot,
which I'll come back to in
awhile, a small town in the
town, they were both miners and
agricultural--they're farmers
and day laborers.
And it's the same thing in
other mines of the Decazeville.
But, still, the number of
people whose principle activity
is industry increases.
And France also urbanizes at
the same time.
Now, the percentage of the
population in 1872 that are
urban is twenty percent,
21.1 percent,
or something like that.
In 1901 it's 40.9 percent.
Now, you're going to think boy,
France is really urbanized,
but that's completely
misleading because to be urban
in France,
as of the census of 1841,
you had to have 2,000 people,
and that's all.
An example I always give is
there are 2,000 people outside
the Meriden Mall when it opens
sometimes, or the Boston Post
Road Mall.
I mean, 2,000 people does not
seem like a major urban
agglomeration.
So, France still is--the level
of urbanization is not
comparable to that of the
Prussian Rhineland before 1871,
or Germany afterward,
or the United States.
If you go to the Naugatuck
Valley and the sort of rustbelt
there--the United States
urbanizes, the eastern United
States urbanizes very rapidly.
France, and we'll come back to
this when I talk about cities,
France does have large cities,
above all Paris,
but it is primarily an
urbanization of very small
places of what in French--and in
English,
the same word--you'd call
bourgs, b-o-u-r-g-s,
which are market towns
essentially,
so small towns.
So, we're still dealing with a
society in which production is
overwhelmingly rural,
but in which France is becoming
a major kind of industrial
producing--a producing country.
And one of the things that
increases the number of people,
the rate of
urbanization--urbanization
really is a growth in the
proportional number of people
living in whatever you define as
cities--is le grand
départ,
or the big departure,
as rural people leave the
countryside and move into
cities.
And this is one of the great
social happenings of this entire
period.
And I've probably used this
statistic before;
if I didn't, I should've;
and I'll use it again,
that in 1851,
two-thirds of all the
departments or
départements in
France had a larger population
in 1851 than they did in 1939.
So, that's really incredible.
So, you have really huge growth
in the industrial north,
and that's what you've been
reading about,
the Nord, that department,
n-o-r-d, and in other areas
with a big major center,
for example Toulouse,
which is the fourth or fifth
largest city at that time,
way in the south,
one of France's most wonderful
cities.
So, you have departments like
that that are growing in
population because of people
leaving the mountains,
people leaving areas of central
France that simply aren't
rentable,
you can't make enough money to
survive,
particularly during an
agricultural depression.
And the wine disease,
talk about a catastrophe,
the wine disease knocks out
much production,
knocks out the way people live.
And down in this part of France
you already had a huge blow to
the rural economy with another
disease that comes along and
wipes out,
or at least severely constrains
the silk industry,
the raw silk industry.
So, people get up and leave and
they go--they enter these new
jobs like teaching,
or clerking,
or working in railroad
stations, and that transforms
the way people live.
And, so, you have to sort of
see all these things,
the kind of flow of people back
and forth, and even some flows
that end.
There was, since the sixteenth
century, this pattern of
seasonal migration,
of men,
only men, walking,
walking every year all the way
from this part of Central France
to Paris,
to Rouen, to other northern
cities to work in the
construction industry.
They started that in the
sixteenth century and they
walked every March,
and then they'd come back every
November,
and so most babies,
if all goes normally,
are born within a three months
period.
But a huge percentage of the
male workforce walks in lines of
two all the way to Paris.
You also have these patterns
from the Pyrenees down to
Barcelona, and from the Alps
down to Milan,
or down to Lyon and those
regions too.
And one of the things that
happens in this course is that
seasonal migration stops and
those people basically become
seasonal migrants,
and the areas from which they
came are de-populated;
depopulation is one of the most
amazing things about rural
France, and that's what--it
still--it has been going--well
the last ten years there's been
a rediscovery of the
countryside,
and a lot of people retire
there and you have the
phenomenon, what you call
villages-
dortoirs,
that are sort of dormitory
villages where people live when
they're working in the city.
But one of the astonishing
things about seeing all the
people killed,
you go and you see the war
monuments,
particularly in the Massif
Central or places like that,
is that when you see all these
dead people,
you see the--you can imagine
their faces, and you see all
their names on these huge
plaques,
eighty, ninety,
one-hundred,
and they're just in these
little teeny towns in which the
countryside has been sort of
abandoned and now may be bought
up by the British but--as in
many places.
But, so, the grand
départ,
the big departure for urban
areas and new jobs,
is part of this entire scene as
well.
So, where is industrial
production in the time we're
talking about in France?
Well where's my little jiffy
statistic?
But in the north,
that is certainly the case.
62.1 percent of the population
of people in the Nord,
that you're reading about,
or maybe even have already
finished this wonderful novel,
are workers.
So, it's the Nord or the
proletarian
département,
along with the Pas-de-Calais
next to it.
And the first sort of
conurbation--a conurbation is
cities that grow so rapidly they
all come together,
like become one city--is Lille,
which had been there for
centuries and centuries,
and then Roubaix and Tourcoing,
which just grow up,
they're little Manchesters in
France.
You find the same thing around
Saint-Étienne.
So, big, heavy mining and
textile industry in this part of
France, for sure.
And the other big industrial
region, of course,
the biggest,
is the Paris region.
But the Paris region you're
still producing these articles
of Paris, that's what they call
them,
these articles de Paris,
which are things like wallets
and shoes and fine quality goods
that are part of the industrial
pride of France.
When they had these big
expositions in Victorian
England, these mass produced
things in England that William
Morris,
the sort of sponsor of arts and
crafts movement,
said it was the age of the
shoddy.
And the French would always
proudly say, "we don't turn out
this Victorian kind of junk,
we make products of quality."
So, you had these fine clothes
still being made by--put
together by single women or
single men,
I don't know if they're married
or not, but working by
themselves at home,
that are part of the artisanal
structure of Paris;
where, if you went into the
hinterland of Paris or into the
industrial suburbs there you
have the dirty industries,
soap production,
chemical production,
that people don't want in the
city and the city values are so
high that if you want space
you're going to build them
outside--more about that when I
talk about Paris.
And, then you have Lyon,
and Lyon was the soap workers'
capital of--really of the world,
in terms of production.
And if you want to find one--if
you're going to go to one city
and see where every layer of
architecture,
every layer of architecture
representing the past is there,
Lyon is the place to go,
because there you've got
Gallo-Roman ruins,
you've got medieval--a fabulous
medieval neighborhood on the
right bank of the Sâone
River,
you have renaissance quarters
that are fabulous.
You have the best
seventeenth-century apartment
buildings that are left anywhere
in France,
you have this
eighteenth-century sort of
classic, the Place Bellecour,
and you have this nineteenth
century industrial suburb,
right on the hill,
called the Croix-Rousse,
where all the--literally all
the buildings have real tall
roofs in order to accommodate
these big silk looms,
which are called
jacquards,
but you obviously don't have to
remember that.
The point is that this becomes
a big industrial center,
and that even as late as the
1860s you still had merchant
capitalists putting work back
out into the countryside in
order to take advantage of what?
Of cheap female labor.
Women make one half of what men
do in any trade in Europe,
any occupation,
throughout the nineteenth
century and well into the
twentieth century.
You have other artisanal kind
of producing towns.
You have-- Toulouse is a big
artisanal center;
Marseilles produces soap,
I could go through the whole
map, but I'm not going to do
that.
You have old textile towns that
are still producing and turning
out lots of things,
like Rouen, which is one of my
favorite towns in Normandie,
where I teach every year a
course that we jam into two
weeks;
and Troyes and places like that.
So but these places are rather
spread apart.
You've got your basic
shipbuilding,
places like Saint-Nazaire,
et cetera, et cetera.
So, though not gifted by having
primary resources near major
waterways, with the exception of
the Loire River,
you still have this
transformation of the economy.
But there was industrial
production of some kind almost
anywhere that you could go.
And, then, you have very
specialized cases like Limoges
which is famous for its
porcelain, maybe more about that
later.
Why is it famous for its
porcelain?
Because there's a clay that you
make porcelain out of called
kaolin,
which was a Chinese term,
that is available there.
And, so, that's why Havilland
porcelain, which no longer
exists, incredibly
enough--Havilland,
it was American,
I said that before--but it
doesn't exist,
they're closing their doors and
there's one really major
producer left.
But, these were part of the
Industrial Revolution in La
Belle France.
And, because it has now been
annexed by Germany--that is,
not now but in the 1870s,
I mean in 1871--I didn't talk
about all the textile production
in Alsace, but there was lots of
textile production there.
And, as everywhere it's the
textile production that is the
cutting edge,
the leading edge of the
Industrial Revolution,
followed by metallurgical
production.
And, as in the case of Britain,
that is, the trains help
encourage investment because
people can see trains,
they can ride trains,
and they look like something
that's going to lead France into
this new,
brand new industrial world,
and so that helps accentuate
the number of people who have
something to invest,
investing in railroads.
As a matter of fact,
one of the things that probably
hurts French industry during
exactly the period we're talking
about,
that is the 1870s,
'80s and the early 1890s,
is the fact that French
capitalists begin investing in
railroads,
but in other places,
in Italy, in Russia,
and in Spain,
where the railroads are to a
great extent built by French
capital.
So then you've got people who
are from--English economists
saying, "oh well,
they'll never catch up with us
because the peasants all hide
their money under their beds or
bury them in the gardens,"
or people that have capital to
invest are investing the money
in these other railroads.
Now, what about women in all of
this?
The role of women in the
Industrial Revolution is
obviously crucial.
In the case of France and in
the case of Sheffield,
around Sheffield,
or Birmingham in England,
the role of women in domestic
industry or finishing products
was extremely important and
extremely persistent.
The Industrial Revolution,
even the second Industrial
Revolution, does not--the story
has more continuities than
dramatic changes in the role of
women in the Industrial
Revolution.
Women had always worked in
textile production,
but they'd worked by themselves
in the Vendée,
or anywhere and in Lorraine or
almost anywhere,
back for centuries.
And they still do.
We've exaggerated the
separation of work and home in
the role of women in the
Industrial Revolution,
because if you look at Paris in
the 1890s--I have a former
graduate student,
Judy Coffin,
who has a wonderful book on the
sewing machine and its role in
all of this.
If you look at industrial
production of these fine
garments and handbags that are
made in Paris,
many of them in the garment
industry, the Garment District
of Paris, which is right in the
center of Paris on the right
bank,
around a street called Sentier,
are done by single women
working on the very top floors
by themselves,
and working for a merchant
capitalist, just as their
predecessors had done two
centuries before that.
And, so, those continuities are
still very important.
But to be sure,
in the more sort of classic,
or the usual kind of thing you
hear,
I'll make in awhile,
to be sure they gradually move
into factory production.
But, what does not change
is--another thing that does not
change is the role of women in
the managing of the household
economy,
because women have to somehow
piece together enough work,
enough income from their
children and from their husbands
or partners in order to keep the
family going,
and women's role in the
household economy is still
extraordinarily important.
Also, some aspects of women and
work that is not industrial does
not change.
In England--in Great Britain,
but let's say England,
in 1850 and again in 1880,
the largest two female
occupations are textile
operatives, factory workers,
and domestics,
and in France that's the same
case too.
And one of the things that
single women do who come into
Paris, or Lyon,
or Strasbourg or whatever,
to try to get a job,
is they place themselves in
domestic service.
And, of course,
their conditions of work are
lamentable, and there's all
the--and often,
often--and there's a whole
range of literature about what
happens to them.
And, of course,
some of the most spectacular
cases of things going wrong are
the ones that you hear about
from social commentators at that
time,
which is the single domestic
service gets impregnated by the
aggressive older son,
or younger son of the boss,
and then, the minute she's
pregnant she is out of there,
and then that is a fairly quick
road, in many cases,
of many rural people to--if
you're pregnant you're not going
to get hired,
who's going to hire you?
So, then what happens to the
baby, in France,
anywhere?
Infanticide or abandonment,
in the foundling homes.
And what they did--and,
so, in order to cut down the
infanticide rate they create
this thing--and it still was
debated again about three months
ago in Rome--they create these
things called tours--I
don't what you'd--tours,
they're tours,
these things that turn,
and they're like the machines
that they used to have in the
ill-fated machine city,
which some of you don't
remember, where you'd put in
your money and,
if you get lucky,
the product will actually come
back toward you,
and what happens there is you
ring the little bell and this
little thing turns and you put
the baby in there,
and then some nice person keeps
the baby, because otherwise you
just abandon the baby and the
baby dies.
And the number of infanticides
every day was tragic.
And once you got into it,
if you were a baby and you get
into one of these foundling
homes, your chances of survival
are very thin.
And every large foundling home
really into the--through the
1870s the number of people--of
babies who die is one-third
every year.
So, that's another reason,
by the way, why French cities,
more people die in French
cities than are born in French
cities,
through much of the century,
because of the huge rates of
child abandonment and
infanticides.
So it's a most unfortunate
scene.
And then what happens after x,
this mother x has her baby,
abandons her baby,
and sadly, maybe in ten percent
of the cases,
kills her baby,
is that the road to
prostitution is a rather quick
one,
coming along;
or try to get back into
domestic service.
So, but, for most women things
go better than that,
but they never go splendidly
because they're never going to
earn what males earn,
and they're the last hired and
the first fired right along.
And, then you had this other
thing that happens,
is that the Socialists are
quite concerned with what
happens to women's wages,
and the unions are quite
concerned what happens to
women's wages,
but they're not very concerned
about whether they have the
right to vote.
Why?
Because the socialists are
afraid that because women,
as I said before,
are more apt to go to church
than men,
by far, then and now,
that they will vote the way the
priest tells them in the
confessional.
So, the socialists do not
support the right of women to
vote.
And women don't vote in France,
they don't get the right to
vote after World War I,
despite all the
sacrifices--they get the right
to vote in Britain--they don't
get the right to vote in France
until after World War II.
So, again, so what changes?
So, keep your eye on the big
picture, is that domestic
industry gradually implodes into
these cities,
into factories,
on the edge of French cities,
big and small,
but that what women do doesn't
change,
they're still doing domestic
industry, they're still doing--I
mean, they're still doing
textile work,
they're not doing domestic
industry;
take that back,
I take that back.
They are doing textile industry
work, but increasingly in
factories, which is the classic
portrayal of the Industrial
Revolution.
And, so, the classic portrayal
ends up being right,
but only rather gradually in
France, over a very long period
of time.
Or take Catherine,
one of the more engaging
figures in modern French
literature, I think it's fair to
say.
Her experience is perfectly
normal.
It's sad, it's pathetic,
but it's very normal.
I'll give you an example.
This is--we live about two and
a half hours from
Saint-Étienne,
and I hardly ever go to
I go there to work once in
awhile, in the archives,
but not that often,
nor do I follow Les
Verts,
which is their famous soccer
team.
But there's still an expression
that people use there.
If a child screws up,
does something--you're nine,
eight or nine years old,
and do something your parents
tell you not to do,
and you do it anyway,
they'll say something like,
deux semaines sous une
benne,
two weeks under---a
benne is a kind of a
wagon that's used to haul coal,
and what children did in
factories, and in mines,
is--because they're small you
can put them under one of these
wagons,
and they help move it along the
tracks--that'd be a lot of fun
wouldn't it?
Because they have little
shoulders, but strong shoulders.
Or fixing machines in factories
with their little fingers which
would get chopped off.
"They're so careless," said a
British manufacturer when a
couple of them kept getting
their fingers chopped off.
And, so, a way of correcting a
child would be to say,
"two weeks pushing that thing
around and you won't screw up,
you'll do what I tell you to
do.
You won't skip school,
you'll go to school," and this
sort of thing.
So, these expressions still
linger.
So, child labor too,
again there is opposition to
schooling from families who need
that extra income,
or that extra labor of children
in the farmyard,
or watching the sheep in the
transhumance,
moving the sheep into the
mountain and all that.
So, again these continuities
and changes are extremely
important.
Now, I didn't,
and I don't think I have time
to do this now but I'll do it
sometime,
talk about the decline of the
French population,
why France simply stops having
children.
I've talked a little bit about
that but I have to come back and
do that again.
I think I'll wait till we're
talking about the origins of
World War I, because that's when
it really frightened people,
because it didn't look like
there'd be enough French to
survive, to maybe fight a war
against all those rapidly
breeding Germans,
and things weren't working
there.
So, what I want to talk to you
about now is how workers viewed
what was happening to them.
And, so, there's really oh kind
of three things I want to say.
The first is quick,
is that proletarianization is
both--and this was a word that
people used--is both an
objective and a subjective
concept.
And the third is to talk about
how workers viewed the factory
and viewed their bosses,
because the period,
particularly 1895 to 1907 has
been called the heroic age of
syndicalism,
or union organization,
and strikes in France.
Now, proletarianization.
We live in a country in which
part of the canon has always
been that in America if you work
hard you'll always be rewarded
at the end,
and that the descriptions of
the late nineteenth century is
people working very hard,
and doing very well,
and moving into the middle and
indeed upper classes and
becoming very wealthy.
Obviously, that's not the case,
that the great exceptions were
the one that people paid
attention to.
There is social mobility in
France.
There used to be all sorts of
studies-- that's what people
did, not me--but in the 1970s
about social mobility.
Social mobility was extremely
limited for people who were born
into the working class.
And in 1968,1968,
the riots, la revolution
manquée--in 1968,
one of the big issues that
students your age had,
and professors my age had,
though I was your age then,
or a little younger,
I guess, was that you could
work your ass off and your
chances of getting into a
university weren't very good
because once you were born into
the lower classes--schools were
schools of elites,
that's what they were--and once
you got through there,
there was no guarantee you were
going to get a job anywhere,
and people were extremely mad
and upset, and they viewed--they
blamed capitalism,
they blamed the State,
as their predecessors had in
the 1890s.
And, so, people who were born
into a life of work,
a life of hard,
difficult work,
that was one--you ended--you
were born into the jobs that you
would get.
And if--I'll give you another
Saint-Étienne example
because that's so important,
Saint-Étienne,
that there were lots of people
who moved to
Saint-Étienne--don't have
to remember this--come from a
very religious part of France
called the Haute-Loire,
which the capital is Le Puy,
and a lot of these people
emptying out that department
moved to Saint-Étienne.
And they don't move.
Some of them become teachers,
some of them are going to get
clerks jobs, if they're
educated.
But they don't do very well and
they live--there are periods
where they're doing all right,
and then they're let go,
and then they're doing all
right and then they're let go,
and it's just--the more you
read about the 1880s and '90s
and sort of memoirs of working
people,
was just the difficulty of
making things work from day to
day, week to week,
month to month, just getting by.
And they learned to hate.
I'm writing a book about a guy
whom I'll tell you about some
day, who really--he said that
love can make you hate.
And he viewed all of this,
and then he set out to destroy
the state that he thought had
made capitalism possible;
but, that's another story for
another day.
So, there's this objective
status of being--you're a
worker, that's what you do,
and you're proud of it,
and you wore blue as a color,
you wore your blue frock or
smock,
whatever you call it,
and you spoke a language in
argot,
read--if you read
L'Assommoir in French,
it's a language that's
extremely difficult to read
because a lot of the expressions
have disappeared,
but it's a way of protecting
your identity.
It's like the way people talked
in the suburbs,
particularly in the 1980s,
1990s, en verlan.
It's a kind of language,
kind of a slang,
of an argot that helps protect
your identity,
that you're proud of your
identity.
And they were proud of being
workers, as well they should.
But the subjective aspect is
what people studied in the 1960s
and '70s, and the term is
class-consciousness.
And, certainly,
there was an attempt to prove
that all workers all over the
place were class conscious.
But that wasn't the case.
People have other identities,
collective identities.
You could have multiple
identities-- family,
religion, region,
we've talked about this,
village, et cetera,
et cetera.
But the fact remains that one
of the reasons why there's so
many strikes in France,
as in other countries too,
it has to do on the one hand
with unionization,
and the sympathetic role of
leftwing politicians in
supporting working class
organization,
but it has--it also has much to
do with people coming to a sense
that they are workers and are
conscious of themselves as a
class and they view the State
and the wealthy people as being
contrary to their interests.
Now, this starts in
France--starts earlier among
artisans in Britain,
arguably in the 1790s,
in France it really starts in
the 1830s, and the word
socialism is first used by a
socialist in 1834,
a guy called Pierre Leroux who
was a utopian socialist--forget
him, but he's an interesting
guy.
But it's at this point where
artisans, not ordinary workers,
see themselves as a class
apart.
So, at the beginning they don't
want to have anything to do with
these unskilled workers,
that they may work with in a
factory.
But they're dressed nicely,
they wore corduroy suits,
and these other workers,
they don't dress like that;
and they're educated,
that's why artisans are at the
forefront, they create the
strike really,
in the early modern period.
It's artisans,
it's skilled craftsmen.
And just in two minutes,
why does this happen,
why do artisans suddenly start
seeing themselves as a class
apart?
Why do they start targeting
capitalism as a structure and
the State as doing them
injustice.
Why?
Well, there are really two
reasons that one can give.
One is that what happens
because of the French
Revolution, to craftsmen in
Germany,
in parts of Italy and in
France, is that it opens the
doors and the guild protections
are gone.
Anybody can be any trade you
want.
Laissez-faire capitalism,
you want to be a plumber,
you can be a plumber;
you want to be a tailor,
you can be a tailor.
And, so, all of a sudden in
Paris in the 1830s,
'40s and '50s there's all sorts
of wagons being pushed through
the street with beautifully made
clothes on them,
going for practically nothing,
because there's so many other
tailors making suits,
and the price,
the wages these guys get--Marx
was right about,
only about that,
insofar as his assessment of
wages--artisans are making less
money, their world is falling
apart.
They have the dignity,
they have the skill,
they have the knowledge,
they have the organization,
in friendly societies,
which at a minimum give you a
decent burial so you're not
dumped into some pauper's grave,
and they're mad because who let
all these other people do the
trades that the guilds had
protected?
And the other thing that
happens is--goes back to where
we started--industrialization
and mechanized production,
that if you go to a market in
Reims, since I used that example
before, or anywhere you want,
in Aubigne or Privas,
and in n'importe
où,
you can go there and you can
buy a suit off a rack,
you can just go and buy a suit,
and you don't have to pay
somebody a lot of money to make
your suit from beginning to the
end,
because it's cheaper.
So, who does that hurt?
It hurts the artisans,
the craftsmen.
And, so, what happens then?
"Ah-ha," somebody with money
says, "hey, you guys are all
tailors, you're not doing so
well are you?
Things aren't real good.
Well, I'll tell you what,
I'll tell you what.
I will pay you to make pants
cuffs."
I don't know much about suits,
as you'll probably gather.
"I will tell you to make pants
cuffs"--do you make pants cuffs?
I guess you have to.
Or to make sleeves on a jacket,
"and all I want you to do is
make one-hundred sleeves on a
jacket.
You make the left ones,
you make the right ones,
and I'll pay you."
It's just like domestic
industry, before.
Are they mad?
Of course, they're furious.
And they go out on strike but
they always lose.
And you can strike in France
after 1864.
So, that's what happens to them.
Or, let me give you another
example from good old Limoges,
in Limoges.
Plates, you got plates,
and plates had always
been--beautiful plates had been
hand painted.
Renoir, the painter,
he started life as a porcelain
painter, and then--and that's
what made it a quality item.
If you find painted Limoges
plates from the 1880s,
you hang onto those babies,
and don't put them in the
microwave.
So, then what happens?
So, somebody invents a process
where you can put,
like a decal on a child's toy,
onto the plate and bake the
decal onto the plate between the
first and second baking.
So, what happens to these
people who are very talented,
who made all this money,
and didn't hang around with
these other guys who make less
money?
They are screwed,
no one's going to hire them.
They'll keep one or two.
I once saw a special order that
had been done for the Shah of
Iran--this was a long time
ago--hand painted because he
wanted it hand painted.
But, that's the end of that.
And they ended up in the
warehouse, or ended up doing
whatever they could.
Or glass workers,
the same thing.
The people that made bottles,
were very skilled and they were
called messieur l'ouvrier en
bouteille,
they were called "mister
glassworker."
And suddenly somebody in the
United States invents a machine
that can make glasses,
bottles, turn out thousands of
them, to be filled with wine and
other things.
Who needs these guys anymore?
And they go on the road to
Belgium or anywhere they
can--nobody needs them anymore,
a machine has eliminated them.
Are they mad?
Oh, and shoemakers,
the same thing,
these machines made in St.
Louis, Missouri,
I think, come along and wipe
out certain aspects of
shoemaking.
So, this leads people to think
there is something that we can't
control out there that is
affecting our lives in a very
ruinous way.
So, these people are at the
forefront of labor militancy.
And in the course of the 1880s
and 1890s they start thinking
about, "hey, you know those
people that we don't drink with,
the ones who load things,
carry things around,
ordinary workers,
maybe, you know,
maybe they got the same,
maybe the same enemy."
And, then they start supporting
their hesitant organizational
movements, and strikes and they
get together.
Now, how did this look from the
point of view of workers?
How do they view what was
happening to them?
Again, we can romanticize
class-consciousness,
we can romanticize this idea of
a moral economy,
that people ought to be paid a
good wage for a good day's work.
And it didn't happen all over
the place, but still it's rather
impressive, and depressing;
impressive the organization,
and depressing the view of
capitalism and the factory as
these units of production get
larger and larger.
Let me give you two examples
how this looked.
One, during strikes what was
the image that workers had of
their bosses,
and what does this tell us?
And my friend and cherished
colleague, one of the greatest
historians I've ever known,
one of the great people I've
ever know, Michelle Perrot,
in France, did work on this
among other of her genius's
works,
the view of the other.
In the 1820s and 1830s,
when artisans went on strike,
they knew the boss,
the master.
The boss was somebody who
they'd see and all that,
and they'd see him around but
they're kind of mad at him,
so we're going to withdraw our
labor for awhile,
we don't--you got to pay us
more,
you ought to be the guy you can
be, you ought to be the guy you
can be and pay us a just wage.
Well, the master,
he has pretty good relations
with them, he may like the noble
in Toulouse,
he may--or around Toulouse--he
may give them a chicken on
Easter, or something like that.
But he's somebody recognizable,
and he's paternalistic but this
time he's gone wrong.
So, we're going to go out on
him, we'll blacklist him and all
that.
What about the 1850s and 1860s?
Why, that is very different
indeed.
The 1850s and 1860s,
if you look at the vocabulary
of the people on strike,
that they still know the boss,
they say to the boss,
but they call him a letch,
he's a letch because he hits on
his female workers,
often with some success.
He's gross, or he eats too
much, or he drinks too much,
or he beats his wife.
They're personal
characteristics in the kind of
language, the gesture,
the gestures and la
parole, the discourse of
strikes.
Now, what about the 1890s,
and the first decade of the
twentieth century?
It's transformed completely,
particularly in big factories,
because something has come
along to change the way people
view their own work experience.
And this is called industrial
discipline, industrial
discipline.
And the strikes--then the boss
is often in Paris sending
telegrams to Limoges saying how
they should deal--they being the
foremen,
deal with the workers.
He has become a symbol of
capitalism, defended by the army
of the State,
in the view of militant
syndicalists,
militant union people who had
the right after 1881 to
organize.
He is a symbol of this
structure of a large-scale
industrialization that they
can't control.
And he is off in his chateau,
on his boat in Normandie,
or something like that,
but he has been--the voice of
him is now the foreman.
And the foreman enters the
game, enters--not the game,
but enters the workshop,
and he represents the attempts
to impose industrial discipline
on people whose parents or even
them had always worked at home,
and you worked when it was
light, or you worked-- when you
had done nursing your baby then
you'd work.
And when you wanted to go for a
stroll to have a smoke or have a
drink you did that.
But the foreman puts up
regulations that you will be
fined if a plate is broken,
you'll be fined for chattering.
There was a horrible fire in
Brooklyn that killed 140 women
who'd been sort of locked in,
in about 1910 or 1911,
because they were chattering,
they were going out in the
back,
instead of working and talking,
and so they all burned to
death.
And the regulations told them
that you will be fined if you do
this, you'll be fired if you do
this.
And the person that enforces
them is the foreman.
The foreman is promoted from
within or, increasingly,
brought from the outside to
impose industrial discipline on
these workers.
The Wedgwood Pottery
manufacturer,
some of you've heard of that,
he once said,
very prophetically,
in 1807 or 1808 he said,
"what I want to do is I want my
workers to be like hands who
move,
and who act,
and who react to the commands
of my brain, and they will do
what I want them to do."
So, the factory--and this is in
England, too,
is--if you can think of
assembly lines,
I used to work at Kellogg's of
Battle Creek.
I did the raisin bran,
I put the raisins into snack
pack, I did that.
And I worked at Alice Love's
Jams and Jellies in Portland,
Oregon, and all this,
and we hated the foreman,
I'll tell you that,
we just hated him;
so, at least I could hate
them--I don't hate them,
but I did hate them,
sure I hated them,
of course we hated them.
But the foremen are the people
who put the regulations up,
who punish you for trying to be
yourself, who--trying to leave
to see your friends.
And then the foremen,
they create these factories as
a way of imposing industrial
discipline.
When you see-- and that's not
the only reason,
because you need factories for
big machines;
these machines I can never--I'd
forget how to work them.
I worked in a canning plant,
I could never--I was supposed
to work this machine,
I could never--I'd forget how
to work it.
It would get jammed all the
time and I'd always get in
trouble.
So that's maybe--it's all
coming out now.
But, what they do is they
create--when you have workers
wanting to have their pictures
taken, when you have cameras;
and when they're taking their
pictures together,
like a football team or like a
baseball team,
they're always in front of the
door, of the factory.
Why?
Because there are very few
doors, and there's a clock over
the door.
It is now the clock,
it's the siren that tells you
when you can come and go;
not when you're hungry,
not when your baby needs to be
nursed, not when you've just had
it up to here with breathing
dust and know you're going to
get TB and croak,
from that, in lots of places.
And that's what imposes this,
industrial discipline comes
from these foremen.
And, so, strikes are often
against foremen.
There was a strike in Limoges
of women workers who were forced
to kneel down and pray before
the workday, and they strike
against women foremen too.
Now, not all of them were
egregious but nonetheless this
was a way of them--a way of
viewing--their experience was
shaped by the necessity of being
at one place at one time,
and if you're not there,
"see ya'," that's the end of
that, you better be there,
and imposed industrial
discipline inside the workplace.
I did a film for--a documentary
for FR3 on Limoges,
on the strikes in 1905,
and we did part of it--it was
one-hundred degrees,
literally, it was forty-one,
and we did it in the ruins of
the Havilland factory,
with dead pigeons,
and plates and the door wasn't
there anymore;
but, I'd seen it before,
you could feel what it meant to
these people,
that they had their pictures
and they said goodbye to
comrades who had been fired,
who had been let go because
there wasn't enough money;
it was pretty bad.
So, the industrial discipline,
in an attempt to create this
kind of perfect workforce,
what it does is it creates
resentment and it helps
explain-- there are other
reasons too--but this kind of
mobilization of ordinary people.
Now, let me just finish with
the following story,
because this is an amazing
thing and a few of you in other
courses have heard this,
but I tell it because it's just
so--it was prophetic.
It was again this wonderful
historian Michelle Perrot,
and she wrote an article I
published in a collection of
essays a long time ago called
"The Three Ages of Industrial
Discipline."
And it parallels the view of
the other, where you're
against--the guy is trying to,
the patron is trying to get
you--the patron was trying to
get you to produce this plate,
and this stuff,
and these shoes and all of
that, and then pretty soon
there's the foreman that tells
you how many things you're going
to do.
But, what happens in the 1900s
at a time when the Olympics
start, and you're counting how
far--or restart,
how quickly you can run the
one-hundred meters,
or whatever?
And an engineer called
Taylor--Taylorism--an American
comes up with a way of measuring
productivity by counting the
units that you can produce,
how many little God-awful bags
of--boxes of raisin bran I
produce in so many hours,
and they count them,
and if you don't count enough
you're out of there,
if you don't have enough-- we
weren't unionized,
we couldn't be unionized
then--you're out of there.
And what happens then--and
Taylorism becomes very
important, Ford loves
Taylorism--and the car
producers,
Renault embraces Taylorism,
it's just an unbelievable
thing.
And there's an old story when a
tailor, or some French engineer,
comes to an American company
and says,
"well, all the workers are
young here"-- this was a
Taylorism place-- "all the
workers are young,
where are the old ones?"
He says, "Come on along,
we'll have a smoke in the
cemetery and you'll see."
And Michelle Perrot said,
predicted in 1978 that the kind
of surveillance,
or the kind of counting of the
assembly line production would
give way to what she called,
in an amazing thing-- think
about our post-Industrial world
of the cubicles of people
answering phone calls,
and doing computer line work
will give way--the way you
measure performance and create
industrial discipline--will give
way to what she called,
beautifully,
the quiet violence of the
computer.
And it did.
See you on Wednesday.